♪♪
Cherry:
That's me.
♪♪
Cherry:
I'm 23 years old and...
♪♪
Cherry:
Somehow I'd always known that
this was how things were supposed to end.
♪♪
Anthony Russo:
Cherry is a very complicated
character.
Anthony Russo:
We focused on his life over
decades and
Anthony Russo:
wanted to find a way to convey
that, cinematically.
♪♪
We're trying to tell a story
but there's so many moving
parts.
Joe Russo: The movie is broken up into
chapters
to portray different experiences
this character goes through.
Joe Russo:
This is about a life cycle for
Cherry.
Anthony Russo:
It starts in a place of real
innocence and youthful idealism.
(Explosion) (Automatic gunfire)
Anthony Russo:
And then it goes through the
experience of war,
Anthony Russo:
P.T.S.D., drug addiction
and bank robbery.
(Gunshot)
Cherry:
Get on the ground now!
One thing about robbing banks,
is you're mostly robbing women,
Cherry:
So the last thing you want to
be is rude.
(Hammer-clicks)
Cherry:
Ma'am, it's nothing personal.
♪♪
Tom Holland:
The scale of what we've had to
do to create this character
and to create this arch for his
journey,
(Pill sound)
♪♪
Tom Holland:
has been pretty daunting.
Tom Holland lost almost a
quarter of his body weight
Joe Russo:
to achieve an incredible level
of realism.
He sort of has this amazing
ability in terms of the looks he's able
to conjure.
We go through 6 or 7
different looks that span 15
years.
Because we're sort of dropping
into moments in time,
Anthony Russo:
The interplay between those
phases, shredded Tom on an emotional level as well.
(Mirror shatters)
I have this noise in my head.
It'll stop.
Emily:
One day it will just...
...Go quiet.
♪♪
Anthony Russo:
Part of what was so fascinating
about this character, was that
Anthony Russo:
he started from a place of
sensitivity and vulnerability
and then things just get worse.
♪♪
What the Russo's have done is
incredibly cinematic. ♪♪
Tom Holland:
They even out high intensity
walks of life,
Tom Holland:
and slowly bring them together,
in a really, really nice way.
♪♪
Ciara Bravo:
Chapter to chapter, Cherry's
journey feels undeniably real.
(Thunder-Lightning)
Anthony Russo:
It's incredibly intense, harrowing
and unpredictable.
♪♪
(Rapid breathing)
Nooo!
♪♪
It's kind of a role of a
lifetime.
♪♪
Tom Holland:
I can't wait for audiences to
just see
this crazy, crazy story.
♪♪
(Sirens wail)
Cherry:
Sometimes I feel like I've
already seen everything that's gonna happen.
♪♪
Cherry:
And it's a nightmare.
♪♪